hey Jordan hello hello how's it going we
just got a first look at Borderlands 3
they revealed that trailer Max and I'd
say you and me are probably the two
people and the GameSpot office who are
liked borderlands a lot
I wouldn't take them out too and would
be the ones that would still care about
Borderlands again true and I don't know
if I can afford it lands anymore it's
too early to say I don't want to be too
mean to the game but the trailer looks
just kind of like my Borderlands which
isn't necessarily bad but I expected
something new the only new thing that I
gather from this trailer is that some of
the cars can hover now and yeah um of
the guns can walk now
yeah I mean so there is a variety of
locations in this trailer but all of it
still looks very much like Pandora yeah
you know there's still the same bandits
over there and most of the trailers
looks like that like when we were
watching this for the very first time we
questioned are they still on Pandora and
it wasn't until the very end that we got
like scenes of cityscape rye and a
jungle but seems weird that these are
just only glancing shots and I'm like
are they still on Pandora is this a new
planet that's basically just Pandora
again which if that's the case seems
almost like a waste are we visiting
multiple planets and they're just giving
us glimpses of what other planets might
look like right it's so far everything
about this looks like more of the same
it looks like no time has passed I mean
the trailer itself is kind of weird
where there is no vio it's all music and
it's it's a lot of fanservice they're
like hey all these characters are coming
back and and as someone who recognizes
these characters I do think it's cool
like hey there's tiny Tina she's older
here's you know sir hammerlock and his
sisters still in the game here's Lilith
and Mya Lilith and Maya Maya's got
longer hair now and like there's all
these nods to these characters that like
you know the fans really love but
there's nothing it's not
saying anything and if I was someone who
never played Borderlands I wouldn't know
what to think of this trailer act right
this trailer feels specifically aimed at
people who have played the franchise for
years now and I've just been asking
gearbox for years now for Borderlands 3
and gearbox like alright alright you go
finally doing it and I guess that kinda
brings up the other point and this is
far more speculative as far as you know
there has a lot of time has passed since
Borderlands 2 and the loot shooter has
changed a lot like Borderlands kind of
was at the forefront of the loot shooter
but in between Borderlands 2 in this
game destinies come out divisions come
out of them gotten sequels both of them
have gotten sequels that there's been a
lot of time in between and you know the
genre has changed and what it does and
what players expect out of the genre has
changed and this trailers not really
gives us any into indication of how this
game is going to work but I'm curious
like what what could they possibly bring
I'm not even sure if most people even
consider Borderlands a loot shooter just
because it came up so far before that
kind of term became popularized and I
would I think it is yeah it's definitely
a loot shooter like the whole point I
think even some of the trailers for
Borderlands 2 it's like look at all the
loot that you can get and it's the
first-person shooters are like they
popularized like yeah but turn this
trailer does that too it's like here's
all this loot also guns wood legs yeah
which I don't know for whatever reason
like that it didn't work for me it was
like weird like in theory I'm like
alright guns like this was cool I
watched him like and actually it's like
why would I specifically bring out a gun
that would walk away and shoot as
opposed to just taking out a gun and
shooting it myself right I think it was
just it's weird how underwhelming the
trailer was none of the humor really
really did anything for me like just
like you said doesn't really come
through without there being any dialogue
yeah it's all through text and so you
don't really get a sense of
and going for what it's doing like I
supposed to Borderlands 2 which I think
had a very strong hook unique you know
like handsome Jack was sort of like the
focus point of that game and and you
know say what you will about handsome
Jack I think you'll have a lot of mixed
feelings about him some really love and
some hate him but he kind of held that
game together
yeah really strong way and this is so
far I'm not really sure what's olden
this came together we have these two
villains that they're showing off
hopefully that they're like charismatic
and interesting enough I do hope so it
looks like she's a siren to witches oh
yeah she's got the tattoos but it's like
at that point that means that there have
been now five sirens and the Borderlands
universe we've met and there's only
supposed to be six in the universe not
sure how that works but okay it's it's
more Borderlands and I'm just I'm
worried that like Borderlands has passed
me by as a person let's say we've both
kind of talked a little bit before this
and mentioned the fact that it could
just be that we've gotten older we
remember enjoying Borderlands 2 in the
pre-sequel and hearing from people older
than us that's like ah this game just
doesn't really work for me and now we've
reached that age and our life doesn't
work for us yeah I can see that like hey
I want to be I know we've been very
negative on it but if you are seeing
this and you're super excited like I
want to take that away from you exactly
yeah that's awesome
I might just not appeal to us anymore
might be outside of our smooth might be
outside of the market but I guess for me
I'm I was looking for something a little
more dramatic of a change because I I
feel like there was a lot of vision for
what Borderlands could have been and and
I feel like the time in between
Borderlands 2 and 3 they lost a lot of
the steam and they could have had and
and it feels like they're kind of just
picking up where they left off and I
don't know I don't know if that'll be
enough fur for new people you maybe
it'll be enough for old fans I feel like
a lot of the people that were involved
in Borderlands or since left gearbox and
and that makes me
just kind of very wary but also curious
like what what is this gonna feel like
how is it gonna like what's the tone
what's the writing you know Anthony
Burch who worked on boards - he has long
left and I'm cautiously optimistic in
the same boat it looks well it looks
like it'll probably be in well made
decent video game based on just what
we've seen but I'm hoping for more I'm
hoping for it - like I want it to
surprise me same eye I've been waiting
years for this and whether consciously
or not and right I'm happy with a few of
the things that I've seen but none of
the things I've seen in this first
trailer surprised me and that's a little
disappointing I want something to be
announced where I'm like I never would
have seen that coming in a Bordeaux
hands game and I'm excited to see how
exactly yeah well there's still a long
ways off before the game actually does
come out and I'm sure we'll get to play
more and see more and hopefully they'll
have plenty of stuff - you actually like
surprised us and then excite us for the
game let us know in the comments how you
feel about it tell us that we're wrong
tell us that we're old men now don't
like Borderlands anymore I'm sorry those
old-timers they don't understand good
humor handsome jack is hilarious thanks
for watching guys
you
[Music]